americans are scaling back their travel
plans this labor day weekend as concerns
spread about the highly contagious delta
variant part of the proof can be seen
with a check of the calendar there were
a little more than 92 thousand coveted
infections in the u.s the week of july
4th the number of cases top 1 million
this week that's more than 10 times the
number of weekly cases from the last big
u.s holiday nancy chen has more
airports were buzzing but not as much as
expected for a holiday weekend i thought
it would be a lot more crowded being a
long weekend but it's not so bad but the
surging delta variant and the cdc's
recommendation that the unvaccinated
avoid travel has caused many to rethink
their plans covet concerns caused peter
monahan of maryland to cancel his
family's vacation to disney world for
the second time it sounds like a
challenging decision
oh it was we had a countdown clock and
everything going
and then you know delta hit
out of the blue the airlines are feeling
it too delta united and american
airlines are all struggling to reach
pre-pandemic passenger loads as the
virus persists we're seeing a big drop
off in onboard bookings we're seeing a
big increase in in flight cancellations
where people worried about the delta
variant and then of course you have the
other compounding factor schools being
back in session
aaa said the vast majority of holiday
travelers will drive not fly even as gas
prices are creeping up after hurricane
ida stalled production along the gulf
coast the monahans will drive to the
beach instead of flying to florida we're
planning to go down to the delaware
shore and at least have fun down there
but it's not disney despite fewer
passengers the tsa is still expecting a
busy weekend at many of the nation's
airports they're advising flyers to get
to the airport early for cbs this
morning saturday mitzi chan chicago